we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
And for all the talk this week about video
games as where we should be looking to understand
the causes of mass shooting.
Something that has been widely debunked academically
and which I have a resisted, uh, all week
and resisted it with fact.
Uh, I got a very interesting voicemail which
says, you know, it's one thing to just say
video games or causing violence, but did the
shooters play video games because we haven't
heard a thing about that.
Take a listen to this voicemail very astutely
making this point.
Hey David, uh, appreciate the work you're
doing.
I'm just curious why nobody's asking about
their game or histories.
If, uh, you know, the always the talking points
is that these guys are all in video games
nonstop and these, this is a thing, you know,
convincing them to kill people I never see
on, on any, uh, news outlets.
The questioning asks about their gaming history.
Uh, obviously they actively bring this point
up when it's a younger person.
And most these mass shootings are committed
by young people all the time, but yet nobody
ever asks if these things are logged.
The X box is a playstation as their hours
are logged and especially if they're playing
live against other people.
There's a record of all that.
Uh, and so I'm curious why nobody ever asks
to see your gaming history or the police have
ever even looked into it.
Uh, I appreciate it.
Hopefully Doug about, actually
this is why I love hearing from the audience.
This is why we have the voicemail number two
one nine two David p.
I'm in this stuff all day and sometimes very
obvious things just go over my head because
I'm, I'm sort of in today's deep, I lose perspective
of some of the basic questions when Trump
talks about video games in the context of
the shooting, when the Texas lieutenant governor
the shooting and when whoever is talking about
video games, do we know if any of these shooters
even played video games?
It wouldn't even make it a causal relationship,
but what are we even talking about unless
they actually played video games and so far
we've heard nothing about it.
Now to be clear, even if they did, it would
be merely a core, a core, a, a correlation,
a Co Co relative relationship correlated relationship.
What word am I looking for here?
It would not actually prove causation, but
it would at least give us something to start
with.
Did any of these people even play video games?
What, what, uh, how much were they playing?
What games were they playing?
Unless we can actually defend these allegations
about video games, they're, they're quite
frankly irresponsible to even be making a
really great of voicemail.
Very much appreciate it.
Leave yours at two one nine two.
David P on today's bonus show we will talk
about who Joaquin Castro doubling down, uh,
after he tweeted the names of Trump donors
in San Antonio.
Of course, that is public information.
Donor information is public.
A man has been charged with assaulting a 13
year old because the 13 year old didn't remove
their hat during the national anthem.
Uh, very bizarre story.
And also we will talk about the possible connection
between vaccines and sorting out the problems
with cow emissions that impact the climate
of planet earth.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, two ways to get access to the bonus
show.
Number one, become a member@davidpakmandotcomslashmembershipnumbertwobecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David Patton show.
I'll speak to you then the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].